hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this interview i'm going to be
discussing with a guy called ben how he
managed in just about two years to
become a property millionaire his
monthly cash flow is around about 10 000
pounds per month and all of his
properties he's bought them he's pushed
the value up and then he's refinanced
and recycled his cash on each one of
these properties it's going to be an
incredible story so stay tuned also if
you enjoy the content you enjoy the
channel do me a massive favor smash the
like button for more videos which will
help the youtube algorithms but right
now ben thank you so much for coming to
my house oh thanks having me so how did
you get started in property so
around about 2019 um
i'd i'd had some time out of work and i
had some time to think and i was uh i
actually read the rich dad poor dad book
as similar to you i believe and there's
somewhere in that book that talks about
um doing a couple of courses every year
just to get ideas and that type of thing
and
i went on to google i typed in property
course london and like your name will
stop the list and then
[Music]
there was like this free crash course i
didn't really know much about it but i
just went in and signed up
for the the course in november 2019 and
then i came along
um
from there i i did some other courses
with myself and then um
early 2020 started finding a patch and a
location that i wanted to invest in
which turned out to be liverpool
and a bit later probably around march
time uh driving up and down to liverpool
trying to find deals meet agents and
mexico
so when you came to the the program
in 2019 it was a particular special day
and and and just tell us about that
because i think the commitment is a
really important part to being a
successful property investor so tell me
about your commitment on that day
because those two days yeah so so when i
uh so when i went online when i sort of
found you on google i just booked the
first one
and i didn't realize that overlapped
with the rugby world cup final
and i'm a big rugby fan so
um
[Music]
it was obviously the finals i didn't
know that england would be in the final
but as it turned out they were in the
final and uh i think the the course that
you did was on the friday and the
saturday
and uh i think you let everyone know
that you know
to get anywhere you've got to be
committed and things like that and then
on the second house
i
really wanted to watch the game but i i
cancelled the the plans to watch the
game and like came to the course on the
second day
incredible commitment but the thing is
though because i think i remember saying
actually nothing wrong with watching
rugby and stuff but you've got to be
rooting for yourself to win more than
you are rooting for
rugby or england team or whatever to win
like you've got if you if people have
the same passion for their businesses as
they do for football
they'd be they'd be property
millionaires and that's exactly what
what you've become over the last couple
of years so good decision and i hope you
watch the catch-up version i did and uh
yeah it was it was a shocking game for
england anyway we lost but um so where
about where where do you live uh
southwest london so you're living in
southwest london what was it that made
you decide to have liverpool as your
patch
a few things really i mean you just look
at the yield uh up up there so
um
one of our houses which we'll come on to
is worth say 90 000 pounds and it takes
600 quid in rent well if you say times
those numbers by 10 so a house in london
you you'd see near me
there's loads of houses near me for 900
000. they'd never get six grand
in rent
so
uh you go up north and you can find the
yield um there's loads of towns where
there are that yield so again you know
why liverpool i just think liverpool's
got something about it it's it's got a
university it's got a football team um
there's it felt like there was a lot of
development just because we were going
and visiting it it felt like there was
development um
going on up there anyway there was a lot
of positive things to attract you up
there yeah
you know it's a big town in the north
and the and the yields there so i think
if it felt like a
i don't want to say that a better town
up north i don't know many towns up
north but it just felt like it had real
something about it yeah it's kind of
like popping there's stuff happening and
it's busy
also as well you came to the crash
course you joined the property investors
academy you've done a lot of you've done
a lot of our courses on the development
brr
what was it that made you make the
decision to invest in yourself because
that's quite a big thing really you know
so what was it that made you decide to
before you invest in property spend
thousands of pounds investing in your
own education and mentorship almost like
the realization that what you know so
i'd worked for probably 10 to 15 years
in in a contracting business that i was
kind of reliant on
and
there was there was a spell in 2016
there was a couple of spells between
2016 and 2019 where that that world
didn't stop working for me and
it had been 100 up to about 2016 and
then there were probably two six-month
periods where i was out of work
um as a result of a downturn in the
market um and i just realized that i've
been totally over reliant on
on a job almost um
and just saw
you know i saw your story as well and
looked a bit about you and just like you
you know you've got this passive income
coming through and i just thought well
if i don't try it i'll never know yeah
um and at that point in 2019 i was back
on my feet working and and so the money
wasn't so much of an issue to pay for
the courses and stuff so so well what
i've got to lose you know it was like
one or two months uh income from what i
was doing at the time the cost of the
academy so i thought okay so
you know imagine i'd spent another two
months out of work well
you know
it's the equivalent of that
but now i've got this course that i can
attend i can meet these new people i can
find out what they're doing get some
ideas
um
it felt like a no-brainer to me just to
try it
great that makes sense and i think it's
everyone's different and everyone's got
a different um everyone's a different
financial situation you were in a
situation whereby you did have a bit of
money behind you you had a little bit of
money to put into property you had a bit
of money to put into education and i
remember you know i mean you know on our
training we teach very much around if
you've got a pot of money if you've got
100 i remember saying this to actually i
think we were at this house on the
discovery day i'm like look if you've
got 100 grand if you sync that into a
couple of buy to let's
congratulations you're going to make 500
quid a month like
the money can very quickly
disappear in property and you really
need to recycle your money and um that's
what you did and it wasn't all fun and
games there were some challenges or
there was there were some scary moments
and we're gonna hopefully get the the
good the bad and the ugly from this
interview and really teach people what
to do but also what not to do but talk
to me through them so you decide
liverpool decide it's your patch the
yields are good it seems to be up and
coming so talk to me about your first
property purchase in liverpool yeah so
so we've been knocking on the doors of
all different agents trying to find
people trying to explain to them what we
were looking for and then we found one
agent
that
was actually helping a lady
buy a whole portfolio from a
receiver so
as we were told there would say 50 or 60
properties that were being sold to this
lady
and her strategy was to sell some of
them
to fund the refurbs that she wanted to
do on the other so if say there was 15
that she was being sold she wanted to
sell 10 but just really in the right
place the right time so
they were all the valuations on these
properties were already quite distressed
because they were in the receivership
and
um
i'm not entirely sure why they got into
such a state but they were really
dilapidated properties as well
so
she
needed a quick sale because she bought
the whole portfolio i think using some
form of finance so it was quite
expensive to her
so she was really motivated to sell we
were motivated to buy and it happened to
be the right place the right time right
so she probably she probably skipped the
class
but she's got these properties so she's
motivated to sell where did you connect
with her from did you find her through
an agent or how did you find her well so
uh
the agent mate was like the middleman
right okay so you went to an agent um so
how do you approach agents so you you
want to buy properties you want to do
brrs you said you've gone you went to
lots of agents what do you say how do
you find these deals uh just just just
sort of kind of being yourself really
just walk through the door having a chat
you know
nothing sort of you know that technical
about it just walking through the door
looking for a property that you know
might have some
uh value added if we do some work on it
that type of thing you know looking for
something have you got something that
nobody wants to buy
um
and then
those types of things and then they sort
of different agents i think some of the
it's probably good to try and find some
of these smaller independent agents
because i think the the hi a lot of the
high street ones
[Music]
are a bit too sort of mechanical whereas
the independent agents they're
we found more willing to try and think
out the box and did you walk in or did
you call beforehand so we called
beforehand yeah uh made sure that there
was somebody there that was
able to speak to us you just call up
small independent agents if you type in
if you go to google and you type estate
agents in liverpool the first the first
page on google you might want to go to
like the 10th yeah and get these smaller
agencies where it's like you know roger
and co and you're actually speaking to
roger exactly you know you're speaking
to the owner and it's his business and
he's got something invested in it as
well and then you're just going to call
up and say i'm looking for properties i
can add value to i can i can fix up
would it be possible to come in share my
share is what i'm looking for go in
speak to different agents bang bang bang
and then you ended up with this
distressed lady so how many properties
did you buy from her so we bought well
three initially yeah
um
so there were three that we bought from
her just under forty thousand each nice
why under forty thousand then there's no
stamp duty so originally the asking
price was forty thousand and i said well
can we call it three nine fifty yeah and
then um
and then we saved it would have been
like twelve hundred quid each on the
stamp duty so by knocking 50 quid off we
saved ourselves three thousand six
hundred quid people would pay 40 grand
for a house and paid because if you if
you paid a pound less yeah you'd save
like 1200 quid so okay so you buy these
three little houses in liverpool and
presumably you bought them with just
your your savings from your job exactly
so
at that point then i've been talking to
a friend of mine mike uh you've met and
um
we agreed that we'd sort of pull our
money and and go in together um
main reason for doing that was that
there's someone sort of like to share
the load in terms because there's a
there's a lot involved in in in doing
the refurbs and and
once you've bought the buying them is
almost like the easy bit and then
um but also you're able to we would
pretty much buying everything ourselves
without any external help so the idea
being that
you know if i could buy one house by
myself
if that goes vacant then i've got 100
vacancy whereas if we buy two together
and there's one vacant there's only 50
vacancy so it's just spreading the risk
as well so you pulled your money
together then yeah with mike who
obviously we also know well
bought these three houses 40 grand um
end figures are we're going to go
through the story of some of the
complications but just just um end
figures so you spent you bought for 40
approximately how much did you spend on
the refurbs on average about 30. so all
in all you're talking about 70 grand and
then what did the final end value come
down to uh the average is about so there
were three it was 85 90 and 92 so just
just under 90 on average so then you
refinance pulled your
initial money out yeah
nearly all of it yeah so the
after fees and stuff you know it's north
of 95 probably okay so you left about
five percent in the deals
um and you've gone on to do that now on
a fourth or fifth at sixth seventh and
eighth so now you've got this whole
portfolio what's the total value of the
portfolio you have probably 1.3 million
1.3 million um with a monthly or annual
profit yeah so they've got low so number
eight isn't tenanted yet that's the
refurb's still ongoing but once that is
complete
the the gross rent annually will be
about 110
000 a year what about your profit do you
know
it's roughly 50
okay so about 55 grand
profit a year coming in from your from
your portfolio which you've just been
recycling recycling recycling to build
quite an impressive story um so i want
to go through some of the challenges
that you've had because i know there
have been challenges
and also just really delve into the
lessons because a lot of people right
now are wanting to do biorefurbish
finance they might be like you where
they've got 50 grand 100 grand whatever
and they're looking to invest it but
instead of just buying one property they
want to recycle it and build a whole
portfolio like you've done
so what were some of the biggest
challenges that you've had and how did
you overcome them i guess pulling the
trigger initially was was quite hard
because even though we had the money
that means you know
some education about it and
just
the comparables at the time weren't
perfect so we were seeing some so where
we were we wanted the 90 grand valuation
a lot of them at the time were probably
closer to 80 and there was like one or
two 90s and you're like well
am i am i going to get the highest in
the area and so
there was an element of it's not the
perfect buy rr but should i do it anyway
um
and again we just thought well look
we've got to try it and
so pulling the trigger i think initially
because we we'd had some
we had as while the lady we're buying
from us distressed she needs us to move
quickly so we've got to move quickly as
well so we've got to go and get builders
quotes and things like that and
um
[Music]
so that was one of the biggest things
was just just learning to move quickly
make a decision you've got to be
decisive because otherwise you're going
to miss it are you quite a detailed guy
so i'm an engineer by background so i i
i am but i
i am
i also sort of like aware of the
situation as well you know so when a
decision needs to be made and you've
only got x amount on the table to make a
decision with yeah you know i'm happy to
make a decision do you think that it's
important that when people especially
like yourself
engineer type backgrounds those
analytical thinkers which i know you are
you might not know how much you are but
you are but do you think it's important
that people realize that in property you
need to be able to make decisions
quickly yeah absolutely because if we'd
have if we'd hang around like those were
good deals what about that deal we lost
yeah yeah yeah but that wasn't you
hanging around was it maybe a tiny bit
uh no i don't think so
um i think we
we agreed like that you wanted me to
have like a decision
uh
by a certain point in the week and i
think we just about made it but the the
agent had um
allowed someone else to go dump it yeah
i think you're about an hour late
we can we can argue the task it was a
while ago now but but yeah i think it's
really interesting point though what you
say because in property when a good deal
comes along you've got to be able to be
educated enough to do your due diligence
quickly because it won't stick around
will it like it will go yeah i mean the
difference with that dude is that we
needed to seek that was a bigger deal
for us and we needed to seek commitment
from other people so
while we got like enough yeses on the on
the table
um
you know there's like a yes but you're
sort of looking at them as like is that
really a yes are you really committed
and yeah um so
i didn't want to sort of pass on a yes
to you when i thought like i've got a
couple of iffy yeses on my side yeah
well that's another thing let's talk
about that so when you're saying yes to
a deal
what what are the risk assessment things
because i always say you need to look at
the best case like the case and worst
case and if you're forced to have to
make a quick decision like for instance
if you're buying a property deal that
comes along with one from auction or if
you're bidding you need to be aware of
what the worst case scenarios are so for
example the deal that we missed on
in your it was probably right that you
didn't give a hard yes sooner because if
you had of and then bang we got it
wrapped up and then you were committed
to having to put down x hundred
thousands of pounds but then your guys
didn't put the money in you're kind of
scuppered and you've hurt your
reputation and you've you know so
sometimes saying yes and being quick
isn't the right thing to do if the worst
case is you're going to be scuppered
financially so what i do if i'm doing a
deal is i think well look i know i need
to make a quick decision worst case
can i live with worst case
if i can live with worst case and if
best case is looking good then i'll
normally just go ahead and go with my
gut but i don't know what you'll take
after buying eight properties brrs being
around the whole training do lots of
deals what do you have to say about that
well
i guess i guess
in terms of the worst case so for the
worst case on those ones that we bought
i guess they were the worst case
for the stuff that just mike and i did
ourselves
it would have almost been the equivalent
of say just buying something so say we
weren't able to like that one um that we
bought the first one of the first ones
we bought forty thousand spent thirty on
it if we'd only got a valuation of 70
which is what we'd spent
it would have been no different to us
just going out and buying a buy to let
yeah so okay it's not the end of the
world you know you'll eventually get
your money back it will still cash flow
a little bit and then you can hope to
get some coverage appreciation over time
so
it wasn't that big a decision to make
but i love that love that
um so basically
worst case you've just bought a house
that you're renting out on a high yield
best case you pull out all your money
the problem comes is when people borrow
money from their auntie and say i
promise i'll pay you back in six months
with interest because i'm gonna put all
my money out and it's like well hang on
a minute what happens if you don't but
because you were using your money there
wasn't that same level of risk there no
exactly and and what's your money doing
sat there anyways it's not doing much
else yeah so um but in the case of the
deal that we talked about and
you know the worst case was probably
like losing a load of money in fees uh
that was non-recoverable so you know in
the tens of thousands of pounds we'd
have lost if those iffy yeses turned out
to be no's which you didn't want to you
didn't want to do that yeah well because
that way you know i can't remember
exactly the numbers but um
it would have been like thirty thousand
thirty to forty grand in the hole yeah
um if the deal went down and that would
have depleted our capital quite
significantly either yeah yeah exactly i
think that um i think you made the right
call and i think i took it to you at the
time you know i don't think that you
were bad over it or anything i'm not
like i'm not bitter or holding on to any
resentment honestly
so okay
problem you did get down valued on some
of your properties yeah so those first
three that we did we actually managed
you know they almost went textbook like
the builder quote
came in pretty much on the money there
was a couple of little variations but
nothing major yeah um and
he started when he said he was going to
start and he finished when he was going
to finish it's like it was ideal really
um so we bought those early september
2020
and they were tenanted uh two of the
three were tenanted um early december
okay so we went to refinance
and we were thinking you know we might
we might go for the the 90 sort of thing
we pushed it a little bit i think we
asked for like 95 or something just to
they always want to give you a little
bit less than you asked for i felt like
um
but they came back so you're only open
to a certain number of lenders when you
you've only owned the property for six
months so we went to those lenders
uh there was only two or three i think
available to us at the time and they
came back and said the houses were
basically worse but we paid for them and
plus the plus the refund money so we got
valuations back of like 70 000.
and i was like this can't be right and i
remember this very well because this is
when you're on the phone to me quite a
bit uh yeah yeah we'd spoken and uh and
you're like you know you kind of i think
you sort of said my expectations would
be too high almost but
that kind of thing where your
expectations too high though was not on
the value which i i thought at the time
was on the time scale because you were
saying to me
i can't wait six months to pull my money
out
i want to get the money out now which of
course as you mentioned limits you
massively on the lenders that you can
use so the lenders that you were limited
to use weren't particularly great
lenders extremely conservative high
interest rates
down valued the property
problem obviously you were really
disappointed um how did you get how did
you get through that well we so we
already had um we bought our fourth one
by that point and we had the money to do
the fourth one so
we weren't so overly concerned in the
sense that we were still progressing
yeah
so we just thought we'd wait
uh we'd wait until we'd own them for six
months
and then
the reality of it was by the time we
were getting those valuations i think it
was
late december early january
and so we'd already had the property
about four months so waiting was only
another couple of months yeah and until
we we got over the six months and then
you got another lender and then we've
got another one
and then it was valued at 90 000 yeah
bank so awesome
well the lesson there i i don't think
there is a lesson as such i think that
um
you know ideally that lender in the
first six months would have given us
what we were doing so i don't think we
did anything wrong um
you know if we'd have refinanced after
three months it would you know we'd have
felt like heroes right so
no i think i think there is a lesson i
think the lesson is that sometimes
things take a while
yeah because they do because you at the
time i wanted everything to be lightning
speed
but sometimes things can take a little
time brr is notoriously slow it's not
fast it takes time you've been in the
business now for a couple years um
coming up coming up to two years to get
to the point where you're at i remember
speaking to you about a year ago and i
was like wow you've got eight houses
come on windows on wednesday and you
were like well i've got our houses but
we haven't refinanced them yet a lot of
them aren't tenanted i just need to
you know make whereas if you were doing
something like deal sourcing or rent to
rents it's very quick but you've chosen
a more passive but slower route which is
which is fine yeah i i guess i saw uh
rent to rent and deal sourcing as a job
yeah it's true to a point it's active
yeah and you're already making good
money in an active job yeah so i i think
we definitely want to think about
getting into deal sourcing because um
you know obviously you're assessing
deals anyway so something that might not
necessarily be appropriate for you could
well be appropriate for somebody else
um
but actually sort of saying i'm going to
quit my job and then make that my job um
it's we're not ready for that yet and if
you enjoy what you're doing and and
you're making good money then then it
might be more appropriate to do a slower
pound strategy like biorefurbish your
finance but also as well with
biorefurbished finance um
if you do a brr in liverpool and it's
just a normal regular br even if you
pull all your money out generally
speaking you're probably only going to
make a few hundred quid profit which is
peanuts because the average rent for
these sorts of 91 houses is like 5 600
quid then you've paid your mortgage
payments your maintenance your
management
it's not really very profitable so
whilst yes you're building your wealth
because you're effectively forcing the
equity up and you're trapping your
deposit in the property so you're
increasing your net worth
in terms of cash flow it's not very good
so
how do you feel about that no i agree
with you so like just take one of those
so one of those 90 grand properties you
know we're probably making sort of
somewhere between 250 300 quid a month
on that
um
and it feels like a lot of money for 300
a month a lot of time and effort for 300
a month so i i do agree with that um
[Music]
um
but it's nice that it's just sort of sat
there now so that should be now 300 a
month you know forever say right yeah
and the house is going up in value
i guess you need a mix right you need a
mix of things you're doing so we focused
on brs for now and and like you say
maybe we need to think about some other
strategies that i mean to be fair on you
though i mean you've got 110 000 pounds
sorry um annual rent roll but i bet the
majority of that is from your few hmos
yeah
but
this is the other thing as well though
so like
again talking about lenders and what you
know there's talk about you know you can
get your first one as an hmo but again
you're going to be limited to a certain
number of lenders that will do that so
we wanted to make sure that we had a
couple of single let's first
um for two reasons really one is that um
it makes your life easier for the hmos
because you'll open up a wider group of
lenders
but brrs tend to be more efficient
if they're a single let because there's
less to be done to them
so if you take
um the amount of money that we we've
we've got a four bed hmo that we've
refurbed the amount of money that it
takes to convert that yeah is is quite
high relative to doing uh so where we'd
spend forty thousand converting
uh sorry we spent uh thirty thousand to
refurbish or two up to down
um you know that you could do
double that yeah
fire doors ensuite smoke alarms
furniture
so you could spend 60 to 70 000 to
convert that into that at that same type
of house not exactly the same sort of
house but not too far off um and then
you won't pull all your money out right
so are you valuing on commercial or on a
bricks and mortar
so on that four bed we got a commercial
valuation yeah a full bed agent got
about 85 percent on the hmos so whereas
the the single letter probably closer to
northern 95 the hmos are more like 85
percent sure so you pull up majority but
you have to leave in a bit of money but
then the the flip side is you're making
vast more cash flow
so it's kind of swings and roundabouts
and this is why it's important i see
being the property investors like having
a toolbox you know deal sourcing brr
hmos and you can just think right let me
just do what's appropriate for the
situation um with your hmos as well you
were smart because you bought prior to
article 4 coming in which i imagine well
i know it was that was part of the of
the strategy
yeah so so one of the properties that we
bought wasn't a bri
it's a it was an operating hmo there is
potential to do it up and probably
increase the rent so there's a brr from
that perspective
so for the future but it's an already an
operating hmo and we knew article 4 was
coming in so we wanted to buy in that
area because once article 4 comes in
you know that potentially limits other
people coming into the market and it
just makes your house like a special
edition house so to speak and yeah you
know you get the grandfather rights does
that happen now then has it uh yes so
we've uh
so once you once you buy that house and
there's already an existing license the
license gets revoked because it's the
license in the name of the previous
owner so then we've applied for our own
license that applications going through
what's your thoughts because i remember
about two years ago maybe less 18 months
ago in 2020 when you were just going on
this buying spree in liverpool and the
media there was news articles by leading
estate agents that were saying liverpool
markets about to crash
and
i know you were a little bit nervous i
think i think to be honest a lot of
people were quite nervous um
that's certainly not what i was saying
you know what i was saying i was saying
no no they're going to rise um and i was
i was i was correct but again
nerve-wracking time
media when we first went into lockdown
the media was saying well the prices did
drop slightly and they let us know how
much is the question how exposed is the
question then they boomed and then the
media was saying
they're about to crash they're about to
crash like
james khan says observe the masses and
do the opposite and you know
how how did you manage to get navigate
through that when you've got so much
noise going on in the media and dave
down the pub and everyone's saying it's
a terrible time to do this don't do it
you made the decision to continue
talk to me about that
yeah so i think the reason
there was that dip because we were kind
of right in the middle of covid or the
early days of covered anyway so 2020 was
the first
run around about
september's home was like within the
first six months of covid so
i think
where like loads of restaurants and bars
and students had all
probably left their accommodation and
gone home
um
they um they left the void so a lot of
landlords would buy to let properties
had a load of vacancy because
everyone went home because they if they
were a student the universities were
closed or if they worked in a bar or a
restaurant all that type of stuff was
closed
so but i don't know i just kind of
thought well you know
it's going to be a short-lived thing and
you know eventually there'll be a
solution and um
i didn't pay too much attention to it
also because
speaking to the agents there was still
quite high demand for rentals yeah so
while the price was going down i wasn't
really
i was only really interested in the end
value
and i knew that we weren't that far off
it so um right
generally
it was going back to the worst case
scenario again
i knew i'd get the 70 000 on the
revaluation but i wanted 90. so
if there's high demand
for families which is what the single
letters were targeting
we weren't really going for the the
student market or that the end of the
market that was seeing all the vacancies
we were targeting a different part of
the market and so it didn't feel like it
applied to us so since that was all said
then october 2020 that was when there
was the liverpool is about to crash
headlines going around
what has happened in liverpool since
october 2012 i think it's topping the
charts uh it's at least in the top five
or 10 in in the last two years in terms
of capital appreciation and house price
increases so the houses then that you
bought since refinance didn't they've
gone up even more i'd expect they have
yeah i we haven't refinanced them yet um
but so i guess two years i think those
first ones were fixed for two years so
september this year so you might end up
refining them again and pulling out all
your money and more so where you thought
it was 95 97 maybe it's 110 yeah and
then we've cash flowed since as well
yeah yeah why out of all the potential
different property trainers and courses
why did you choose me to be your
property trainer and mentor yeah so
so i obviously came along to the crash
course so
when i was looking for like property
courses in london like you you were top
of the list i think you were the first
one on google and i didn't know you at
the time from any any different from any
others so i
booked the crash course it was obviously
quite accessible as well doing the crash
course as well and it felt like an easy
way into trying it
but then um you know i thought at the
crash course i thought it was quite a
powerful course you know i thought it
was quite um you know
i can't remember how big the room was
that was one in did a nails court
um a thousand people there was a lot of
people there and i just it just felt
like oh this is quite powerful that you
were able to kind of attract that amount
of uh an audience and then
i thought there was a lot of value in
the crash course i really liked some of
the stuff that was was in there i don't
remember all of it quite now but i just
remember at the time
thinking um
you know i really liked what i heard so
i think and that's why i signed up to
academy that weekend anyway yeah
was it a good decision
yeah definitely i i feel like um you
know i've
got loads of great ideas i mean the
thing is with the courses in that and
the courses in reality there's you've
got to accept that there's there's the
life lessons that you you get for
actually doing it but i thought it was
it was a good foundation of ideas in the
courses and and a great network and
and i think
um you know i've obviously gone on to do
other on top of the academy the
development stuff of you as well which i
enjoy as well so um
yeah nice it's been a really good
decision i really enjoyed it and i think
as well just being able to pick up the
phone is important because you don't
when you're doing a deal sometimes if
you've got no one to check your blind
spots you know what i mean yeah
absolutely yeah so like
anthony and dave and alistair and those
guys um
you know they've all been really good
what do you think about your plans for
the future like what what's the
you've obviously got this nice 1.3
million pound property portfolio in
liverpool what what what's next
so we already had a half an eye on that
so in the middle of kovid i think you
were doing these like discovery days and
um
i even paid on top of that to come and
come i think that's the first time i
came here brought mike down
uh that was another time but i think the
first time i came in by myself right and
um
and then i think you were only you're
only a couple of weeks away from doing
your um development uh course
and then i came in and i joined that and
so we all had half an eye on development
as well we've been being the future
nice um
[Music]
so we haven't
done anything yet we've got another
property that we've we've sort of lined
up in london
uh which has got you know a lot of
potential to flip
and so we're gonna
it's not a development as such it's
still just a loft conversion extension
which is similar to some of the stuff
we've done in liverpool but it's
it's just a bigger scale
it feels like a natural progression stop
putting some zeros on the end yeah yeah
it just like the work isn't involved
isn't that much different it's just
because the location involved
uh it makes it much more lucrative are
you proud of what you've done yeah
absolutely yeah i feel like um
you know it's taken a lot of effort on
both mine and mike's part but um you
know we've got there eventually you know
how do you juggle your time on top of a
very demanding job because you're still
in your job because you like it and you
paid well
but how do you juggle being able to have
a high paid corporate job working in
construction
alongside
running a property business
it's lots of things really i mean like
you know i pick my moments when i'm when
i'm gonna go up to liverpool obviously i
you know take time off when it when it
suits work that type of thing
um you know family life
um
you know there's compromises there who's
had a baby yeah congratulations thanks
man yeah
so um
you know fortunately my wife uh you know
takes a lot of the uh the pressure off
there like by looking after the kids
when i need to go and do stuff so
um you know my wife is very good that
way she you know she's making sure the
kids are happy and giving me you know
she's helping me like
not have to put time in with the kids so
much so that she can
she does that so i can um i can do this
because obviously
ultimately it's for us at the end of the
day so it's just that having that
balance that compromise as a family
yeah and then um you know like having a
partner you know bouncing things off
right so when i've got down time and
work and i can take time off it's you
know it's different for mike so that
having a partnership it definitely helps
like if i go on holiday
mike looks off things and vice versa
um
so you know like having
you know
having a wife that's supportive and a
good business partner
to the main factors and then you know
sometimes you just have to put the hours
in uh when it's necessary you can either
find excuses or you can get rich yeah
and a lot of people are like oh now's
not the time for me because i'm at una i
wait until i finish but it's like hang
on then you're gonna have a job yeah and
i've got i've just set into my job oh
i've just had a baby oh i've just had
this now's not the right time it's like
no never's the perfect time no one's
ever just sat twiddling their thumbs
doing nothing that's never going to
happen if you want to get rich you may
as well just say you know what i'm going
to go to the crash course i'm going to
miss the rugby
i'm going to book some i'm going to
choose a patch i'm going to get a mentor
i'm going to take some trips to
liverpool and regardless of how busy i
am
you know everybody is busy exactly
there's no there's never a good time and
now you know like you just gotta go with
it you've gotta try it you know you use
something on your leaves if you're in
work right and just uh take some time
off and go next well huge congrats on
what you've done um it's been good
working with you yeah and i'm really
glad to see what you've built with
together with mike um and i'm excited
about your future so there you have it
folks i hope you enjoyed the discussion
with ben if you want to connect with ben
i'm going to leave his linkedin details
below in the description also if you
like them if you want to come to the
property investors crash course and you
want to learn your property investment
strategy there are limited tickets
available but right now they are free so
i'm going to leave a link in the
description as well where you can get
booked on to the property investors
crash course if you want to see more
interviews like this as well there's a
whole playlist right here where you can
check out a whole bunch of people's
stories how they become financially
independent through property come to the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link right here subscribe and we
will see you next time
[Music]